here now Miranda deine she is a New York
Post columnist and author of the laptop
from Hell Miranda you've been
investigating Hunter for many years you
now see an indictment with many of the
details that you wrote about in your
book laptop from hell what's your
reaction to this
indictment look I mean it's very late
and really too little um some of the
most serious charges of course were
allowed uh to lapse uh the statute of
limitations was allowed to expire by
David Weiss the US attorney in Delaware
uh who he and his prosecutors as we were
told by the brave IRS whistleblowers uh
just blocked and uh styed and delayed
all the normal investigative avenues
that should have been taken uh by Joe
zagler and Gary shapley when they were
investigating Hunter Biden and so all of
that was to protect Joe Biden and
ultimately um it ended with that
sweetheart plea deal which they tried
tried to rush uh to get the whole thing
off the their plate but by that stage it
was too late I think um the Gary Gary
Chaple and Joseph zegler had really
scared uh everybody they' managed to
scare off Leslie wolf who was the
prosecutor who had been doing most of
the cover up uh according to them and
there was a new Pitbull prosecutor on
the on the case Leo Weiss and uh David
Weiss the US attorney just had to step
aside
and uh let the case take its course and
so now that's what's happened without
some of the more serious charges um and
I think people ought to realize back at
home now that you know you're getting
all this uh sympathy play and Hunter's
lawyer Abby LOL is going on the airwaves
and saying oh poor Hunter was a drug
addict when all this happened he was
clean and sober in 2020 when he filed
these allegedly fraudulent tax returns
in which he was claiming you know $600
and some, for prostitutes and uh you
know a couple of hundred thousand for
clothes Etc so um you know the the
average American uh pays their taxes and
they go to jail if they are fraudulent
and that's all that Joe zler and Gary
shapley wanted they just wanted hunter
Biden to be treated like any other
American taxpayer because otherwise our
faith in the system collapses you know
Miranda while the details of this
indictment are scandalous they're not
truly the Scandal that matters the
Scandal that matters is not how the
money has been spent but how the money
comes in and Hunter is saying this whole
idea of the Biden crime family being
paid from Ukraine or China the bank
records the emails the photos he's now
saying Miranda that it was all made up
by Donald Trump watch this the Biden
crime family okay the Biden crime family
by the way you guys as a crime family
are the really saddest crime family in
history no but really think about this
okay my dad has been a senator since I
was 2 years old he has released decades
worth of his tax returns he has lived in
the public light we have lived in the
public light we have gone through four
presidential campaigns my entire life
has been before the public it took until
oh lo and behold Donald Trump figured
out that somehow this is a criminal
Enterprise I mean like it begs crul but
we sit here and we talk about it and I
turn on ABC ation this morning or see
and they're talking about well Hunter
Biden's plea deal and this that and the
other thing and who knows what happens
with James comr and they may find are
you kidding me I mean I really just like
okay we're going to talk about Ukraine
again I would hope so to the point
Miranda I would hope so this is the true
Scandal how the money was earned not how
it was
spent and that's right and that's why
next week um when the Republicans uh
bring their vote to the floor for
formalizing this impeachment inquir
every single Republican should be voting
yes to that and if they don't you have
to think that there's something
suspicious going on and that they're
being bribed or they're being
blackmailed because there is no
Republican who should not want to get to
the bottom of this influence pedaling
racket this corruption that goes right
to the top of this country and that Joe
Biden has been practicing for decades
and he brought his son Hunter I feel
sorry for hunter in some ways uh in as
The Bag Man and um and now he's being
rumbled and I think in January there are
going to be um some witnesses that come
forward to that impeachment inquiry that
are going to cause Joe Biden a lot of
headache and you know it's hilarious
that Hunter Biden mentions Ukraine and
says oh we're not going to talk about
that yes we are that is the most serious
quidd proquo um that we're aware of at
the moment and it's been covered up uh
quite expertly to the point where they
managed to um imp impeach Donald Trump
over Joe Biden's sins so I think that
will all be remedied uh and but you know
obviously Hunter Biden is going to get
pardoned and that's why he's so cocky
that's why he's going on this podcast
and talking about Russian disinformation
there's never any consequences for him
he doesn't care um but that's really
irrelevant he may be pardoned and never
see a day in jail and remain You Know
Rich and and get famous but but uh but
Joe Biden will be exposed as corrupt and
hopefully the influence pedaling uh that
goes on in Washington will be stopped
hopefully thank you Miranda hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else